- I don't know what just happened.
- [Dr. Bhanusali] You're in an office.
- No way.
- Do you remember us?
- No. Who's you?
- 6:00 AM. Crazy day today.
You're coming with me.
National television shortly,
Chuck Schumer,
flu shot,
getting my eye checked.
They had a laser on my face.
First things first, though.
Got to walk the Bear.
Bear, where are you?
While we're walking the Bears
I wanted to...
Obviously, as I'm trying
to tell you a story,
Bear's just like...
Just to do a little rundown
of what's going to happen today.
First, we're going to head
over to Dr. Bhanusali's office,
who's my rock star dermatologist friend.
We met not too long ago,
probably a year ago at
a medical media event.
He's letting me use his office
to actually give Chuck
Schumer his flu shot.
If you don't know,
Chuck Schumer is the
Senate Minority Leader.
He's also a good friend of mine.
We worked together on
getting EpiPens on planes
after my little fiasco
over the Atlantic Ocean.
He wants to get his flu shot,
and I love when
politicians put their money
where their mouth is.
Where their mouth are?
Where their mouths are?
Dr. Bhanusali?
- How are you? Let's do the pound.
- Yes.
- Long time.
- I know to do elbows-
- [Senator Schumer] Because
you can't touch your-
- Exactly, and the CDC
just updated guidelines
for aerosolized particles,
all that good stuff.
- I am getting this flu shot
because it's so important
for everyone to get it,
now more than ever
with COVID out there.
It's not just your ordinary flu shot.
It's the same shot that
we've had for years,
but with COVID out there,
it's really important to get it.
So I'm getting it bright
and early on Monday morning.
- [Dr. Michael] Bright and early.
Do you have any allergies?
- [Senator Schumer] No.
- [Dr. Michael] No
allergies. No egg allergies.
I like the pink shirt.
- Yes.
- Solid color.
All right, so this is
going to be pain-free here.
- [Senator Schumer] Okay.
No problem.
- That's it.
- It's easy. It's simple, everyone.
It doesn't hurt.
- [Dr. Michael] And Dr.
Michael will do it for you.
- Dr. Michael will do it for everyone.
We can have lines around his office,
but as there are anyway, it
protects other people too.
It protects your family.
It protects your neighbors.
It protects your
community. So get it done.
- [Dr. Michael] And hospitals are going
to be so taking a hard hit with COVID.
So many people are going
to be getting sick.
We can't have flu people
coming in as well.
We need to keep everyone healthy.
So thank you for leading by example.
- No, no, no.
- Now we'll do the elbow bump.
- If it wasn't COVID, I'd give you a hug.
- Save it.
Schumer brought donuts.
What kind of senator brings donuts
to a doctor's office?
We're supposed to be healthy. Mm!
Dunkin? Ooh, which one do I want?
Jelly? But I have to lower the mask.
So I'm not going to do it.
Also I gotta get the... hmm?
- [Narrator] A little longer
than a few minutes later...
- I just did TV talking about coronavirus
and how it's aerosolized
and it can live in the air.
Maria, we in the scientific
community have known this
for quite some time.
It's nice to see the CDC add
this to its formal guidelines.
Now we're about to have a
consultation with Dr. Bhanusali.
Come in here, Dr. Bhanusali.
He runs the best, the
biggest dermatology practice
in New York City.
- I appreciate that.
- And he doesn't do just cosmetics, folks.
He actually helps people who are in need.
Tell us about the few cases
that you've done recently.
You had someone who got knife-attacked.
You helped them with their scar.
Someone who had a dog attack,
actually the really popular
thing that was in the news
with a young boy saving his sister's life.
You helped them out pro bono.
I know you don't like
taking credit for it,
but I'm forcing you to do it right now.
Tell us why you did it. I
mean, look, we're doctors.
We're supposed to help people, right?
That's our duty. It's our purpose.
Cosmetics is fun. We do a lot of it,
but you have to remember why you go
to work every day, right?
And we had a super sweet girl
who was just going to work
like everybody else.
She was attacked and
slashed across the face.
It was close to my old
office. We helped, right.
And you couldn't find the
scar now if you tried.
And Bridger Walker was
the more recent one.
His story went very global.
- Yeah.
- He's a little boy that
stepped in front of a dog
so his sister wouldn't be attacked,
and he was six years old.
And when they interviewed
him, they were like,
"Why'd you do it?"
And he said, "If somebody should die,
it should be me." It's
like a six year old, right?
So you have to help somebody.
- I want to be that brave.
- It's one of those things.
I mean, again, purpose
is really important.
So we're lucky and we're blessed
to have tools and equipment
to help those kind of people.
And we do our best to do so.
- For sure.
All right. So what are we
doing today? Talk to me.
So for the audience who
doesn't know, check this out.
I have a stye in my eye.
That's right, I rhyme.
This thing has not gone
away in six months.
Press on it. Feel it.
There's a big ball in there.
And I've tried massaging
it. I've tried compresses.
I've tried everything.
- [Dr. Bhanusali] We'll do
a little baby injection.
- Oh, we're doing a baby
injection to the eye.
I'm scared. Should I be scared?
It's funny. We got Chuck
Schumer his flu vaccine.
And now I'm about to get a
little steroid in the eye.
Can I go blind?
- [Dr. Bhanusali] I mean, it's possible.
- [Dr. Michael] Okay. But can we not?
Is it going to hurt?
- [Dr. Bhanusali] Eh, talk about it later.
(bossa nova music)
Poke, poke, poke, poke, poke.
Good?
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
I thought I would be going
to a dermatologist's office
to get Botox, not to get
my eye injected for a stye.
- [Dr. Bhanusali] Give
it a couple of years.
- Tell the audience,
what's the purpose of getting
the steroid injection?
- So essentially what happened,
there's an inflamed follicle in there.
- Yep. Hair follicle, right?
- Exactly. And we tried
the warm compresses,
all the other good stuff.
Sometimes you have to just
drop a little bit of steroid,
a little bit, just to calm
the inflammation down.
It'll reduce the swelling,
which definitely is occurring.
- Swelling, and some days I wake up
and it's more swollen than other days.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- And a little bit of pain probably too-
- from time to time.
So this will kind of calm everything down,
let your body kind of
go back to equilibrium.
These are super common.
Around the eye not as much,
but we do see them quite a bit.
And so usually it takes
one or two injections
to really get it to go.
- Hey, we're moving.
We're moving and grooving.
So what do we do?
So because of all this stuff
with social distancing and everything,
we want to minimize the
amount of people having
to interact with staff and all that stuff.
- Yep.
So I would just press Room 6,
and then my guy would
go show you to the room.
- [Dr. Michael] No way. All
right, let's follow him.
What's his name?
- [Dr. Bhanusali] We call him Timmy.
- [Dr. Michael] Timmy.
Timmy, don't get nervous, buddy.
Let's go.
Does he talk?
(Dr. Bhanusali responds faintly)
Is this the room, Timmy?
Oh, arrived at Room 6.
Thank you, Timmy. I appreciate it.
I'm ready for my closeup.
You see the little vein here?
He's going to make it disappear.
I love it.
Senator Schumer's vaccine
has turned into a spa day.
This is our friendship in a nutshell.
Anytime you need a prostate
exam, come on over.
Am I putting these on?
- Yeah.
- Men in Black? Are they upside down?
(assistant murmurs indistinctly)
I have a big head?
- No.
- I was going to say,
it's the opposite.
- Sorry, sorry.
- I have a little head.
This is like Men in Black.
Are you gonna erase my memory?
Where am I?
- [Dr. Bhanusali] Three, two...
- I don't know what just happened.
- [Dr. Bhanusali] You're in an office.
- No way.
- Do you remember us?
- No. Who's you?
Is it gone?
♪ I can see clearly now
the (indistinct) is gone ♪
Do you see it's missing?
- [Dr. Bhanusali] So we
just used a 532 laser.
Essentially, we have lasers
that can target different things.
So if it's hair, it'll target pigment.
With something like this,
it actually targets heme or
the redness that you see.
So if you had rosacea, we can
do a full global treatment
just to reduce the redness.
For little capillaries like Mike had,
the laser kind of goes
micro into this vessel,
and then the vessel, poof.
- There's a quote that
I'm going to massacre,
but it's, "If technology is good,
there is no difference
between that and magic."
And you just said poof, and it went away.
All right, successfully
injected the Schumer.
Sam, you ready?
- [Sam] Yeah, we did it, baby.
- Dan, you ready?
- Schumer's a good man.
- Schumer is a good man,
and now he's protected against the flu,
and thereby he's protecting
everyone at home as well.
Now we're heading back to the studio,
crossing the street.
We're safe.
And we're going to record
another video right now.
- [Narrator] Three hours later...
- All right, we had a lunch break,
had some pizza, 'cause it is
technically a cheat day for us.
The lights are lit,
and I'm about to record a
really fun video taking a test,
but I won't tell you what kind.
Also, I have a revelation to make.
October is going to be collab month.
And we've already recorded
some of these epic collabs
with some of the most popular YouTubers.
Some that you've requested,
some that you're not even ready for.
It's going to be epic, epic, epic.
So I just wanted to share
my day with you today.
It's a crazy day.
I think it's the craziest one hour
I've had in a really long time.
National TV, flu shot to a Senator.
Eye injection, my eye's still healing.
Look at it. Look at it.
Now we're filming some more videos.
Back in the hospital tomorrow.
In fact, if you want
to see a day in my life
that I shot in the hospital, click here.
I'm going to be recording
a new one of those soon.
Or if you want a really good laugh,
check out this TikTok video
that just dropped last week.
As always, stay happy and healthy.
(whimsical music)